oh leo you you you you ranked leo way
too high he's the greatest actor of all
time
oh and it's not even close guys
this will be the last one because
leo's the definition of range he doesn't
want to start
[Laughter]
people flick their fingers like that
that's not home
but they do gilbert can you count mom
down it's jews
thank you that's pretty good
hey goomba you've been a great actor
this whole time yeah
[Laughter]
yeah okay okay so then why is he the
best actor that was so easy what i just
did that he's a slave owner which is the
greatest slave owner of all time he made
slave owning cool
uh
oh you black i guess not [ __ ] i like
calvin you watched it don't tell me you
watch django and when the first hour to
have the movie is great when he comes on
screen that's when you tuned in
that's when you were like black or white
that's when you locked the [ __ ] in
though it's when calvin got off stage
it was but it wasn't the stakes got it
real yeah when that [ __ ] red
coat showed up boy you see him turn
around and look at the camera
and he's [ __ ] like you know what i
mean this two [ __ ] just fighting and
he's like
bro
out of here out of here
this is old
like all of it's fire okay
damn there you go it's been the wolf
the wolf of wall street
and he was the wolf
you know what i'm saying i'm good she'll
want to ask her for that one the part of
his range bro you believe he's a [ __ ]
uh undercover time in hollywood he's
great oh my god just a [ __ ] failed
actor i mean come on denzel could never
i love you dan i love you bro but you
don't have to be a [ __ ] getting eaten
by a bear slave on him bro before i get
you up here with him
that would be a fire movie baby
they don't give those roles to black
people oh [ __ ] that's a different
argument i'm not hey i'm not talking
about the system i'm talking about what
it is oh we don't know what denzel is
capable of josh
i disagree because denzel you're denzel
washington you have the [ __ ] prowess
to pick all these roles over a lot of
these [ __ ] white dudes who get there
are some movies for sure denzel could
get before christian bale if he wanted i
think denzel knows that [ __ ] i don't
know how to be a crackhead boxer
i just think i think denzel knows his
name i think denzel could have played
the [ __ ] brother in that movie
no i'm saying denzel could have played
mark wahlberg's sibling
[Laughter]
yeah he's gonna bring things up they
don't listen they're gonna take the
meeting this is such a true story
genetics all right it could happen you
never know but yeah he ain't picking
does ellie pick him out his range box
which is smart but that's why i'm sorry
bro you got up to be to be up there with
[ __ ] leo it goes leo christian bale
dale day you can switch day all day
christian bale depending how you feel
but that's the that's the three
daniel they got range that's israel yeah
inside man denzel not angry
no inside man he's just a smart
guy he's smart yo denzel's the man dude
i think denzel got it
it's the greatest of all time
because what he does is so great because
what he does it's like steph curry can't
really get to the basket that well right
he can't dunk he shoots
the best yes he doesn't defend that well
but he shoots the best and then because
he shoots the best he uses that to make
everything else he does that much better
so he can get to the basket because he
can get guys to bite for the job tom
brady he elevates everything around him
no we're wrong he just does one thing
incredibly well he can't scramble he got
no pocket movement denzel's aaron rodney
like no tom brady's leo
no you say that diversity and skill is
what makes someone a good actor yes
well tom brady ain't got that he got the
one skill no tom brady's skill is i am
the best football player ever but aaron
rodgers can run he can throw he could do
it all right aaron rodgers could pick
him up
he's on third and 11 no problem tom
brady not doing it football acting's
different right
definitely yeah
i guess it's the same
i'm sorry bro leo's the goat mm-hmm
dale day in christian bale and it's
simple and it's because of range and
goat is tom brady
that's what i'm saying like because
you're like oh he's stefan it's like
i'll give you that dizzy stuff but
lebron or michael lebron is leo daniel
day is not my top five bro what he's
just doing because i don't like no no
i'll be honest i like actors that i can
see them in the role that's why i like
denzel because i i think it's denzel i
don't think he's playing a character
that is denzel
like denzel is that guy so you like
badass
nicholas cage is probably the greatest
american actor
michael jordan and space jam
not that good bro sam i don't like
samuel jackson tarantino said he's maybe
the best actor he's ever worked with i
think about saying that what
son i don't know tarantino said that
[ __ ] though and that's he's saying [ __ ]
i don't disagree with you i'll just be
saying this
you're not wrong whatever black guy lets
me say the n word a lot yeah he's the
best actor ever
just be saying that [ __ ] right like come
on no i think daniel day lewis i don't
know who he is which i'm sure you like i
don't like that
so i don't need to see the daniel
day-lewis movie but if denzel's in some
[ __ ] i'm like ooh we got two hours of
denzel
into it i kind of feel that way about
leo a little bit i'm like okay i like
this yo george clooney love it yeah he's
fire he's great he's got some range but
i like the man bro ocean's 11.
you like him
he's the man everybody like the man bro
i want to see hero i want to see a hero
of the next movie he's a [ __ ] that's
what i like
look at this bitch-ass [ __ ] also
another reason denzel not funny leo's
funny and to be funny it to me is the
hardest kind of acting there is yes
community acting is by far the hardest
that's why none of them can do it and
the [ __ ] that can be funny you
can't pretend to be funny
you can pretend to do everything else
you pretend to be sad you pretend to be
happy you pretend you can't pretend to
be funny you can't pretend good timing
bro yeah you're either funny you're not
funny yep simple as that like dude there
are guys like how do you feel about jack
black as a comedic actor top five dude
like he's unbelievably funny yes like he
just is funny he knows how to be funny
he oozes funny like and
maybe it's you know
career choices these types of things but
he has almost like that um jim carrey
thing where he can make things that
aren't funny funny just by either
physicality or delivery or all these
things that is [ __ ] hard bro no lines
here ten minutes in the scene no lines
be funny and have the house dying he
could do it impossible that's and that's
what makes it so that's incredible
though yeah that's incredible guys thank
you so much for watching that flagrant
two clip but before you go i gotta tell
you about blue chew you need to deliver
the woman you care about the best dick
that you can possibly give her and the
way you're gonna do that is with blue
chew you don't wanna be like certain djs
out here find out you've been married to
a girl for 10 years and then she never
came no you cannot do that so get blue
chew give her the best dick you can
possibly give her and the way you do
that is by going to bluechew.com and
entering the promo code andrew and they
will give you your first order for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars
shipping again that is
bluechew.com promo code andrew now go
watch another flag in two clips
you